it started with a dream of course you
know the dream of creating something
completely unique completely crazy could
really out of the box and we wanted to
make something that looks like a concept
and yet is a production road-legal car
our market is very different than
Lamborghini the Pagani landholdings and
go even we're very good friends with all
of it
and yet we wanted to make something
exclusive we're focusing and hype this
hyper car to be nice acidity luxury
performance and design we have seven
hundred and seventy horsepower 0-200 240
seconds we can reach 40 km/h we have the
suspension that raised the car five
centimeters in case you're driving the
car in the city so you can drive it
normally we can have rubies sapphires
emeralds put inside the lights and so
when you turn on you have also this
beautiful color we have 24 hours
concierge service that comes with the
car there are only hundred members of
this global elite membership there were
that's in the world it comes with a two
hundred thousand dollar watch which is a
very limited edition only seven watches
in the world
one for each car the car is completely
handled takes three thousand six hundred
hours to build one cars eight hundred
hours just to paint the car this is 16
layers of paint hand-painted but the
hologram this is a completely unique
system that was developed by University
of Tokyo this is a three-dimensional
image that flies in midair
giving the passenger and the driver
pulled tactile control and interaction
with the vehicle today luxury change
back in the days luxury was that nice
wooden materials a nice LED very little
feeling luxurious inside today modern
luxuries the ecology